hey guys this is Vadim with max deck and
in this video we're gonna be comparing
the video quality between the iPhone 11
Pro Max and the samsung galaxy s 20
ultra so let's start off we've got both
of these phones in 4k 60 mode right now
so we're gonna be testing out a few
things first of all let's test out the
stabilization I can't really tell but
you guys let me know which one looks
better more stable and just to make it
interesting I'm gonna run a little bit
I'm on a rooftop right now our office
building now one thing I just noticed is
that on the Samsung it seems to not be
able to focus I don't know if the
autofocus is turned off in 4k 60 like
uncomfortably close to my face and it's
all blurry whereas the iPhone perfectly
sharp so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
switch it to you for K 30 and see if the
autofocus turns back on all right now
both phones are at 4k 30 and yep now the
Samsung is focusing now let's see which
phone does better at autofocus speed
all right so autofocus is pretty quick
on the iPhone let's test the Samsung
can't really tell you guys let me know
if it's performing as well as the iPhone
now I'm gonna try to hold them pretty
still just to test for K detail between
these two I'm gonna crop in a little bit
let me know which one's more detailed
one thing we noticed on the s20 ultra is
that when you use the a K mode it
actually crops in quite a bit as you can
see on this door now switching to 4k you
can see the full frame that you're
supposed to be seeing on the s20 showing
how much of a crop you get with a K in
this shot we're comparing the
stabilization between 4k 24 on the
iPhone and 8k 24 on the s20 the iPhone
definitely stabilizes better and we also
noticed that the a K footage was pretty
dark and underexposed and you can tell
by looking at the trees in the
background now comparing 4k 30
stabilization the iPhone still does a
little bit of a better job but you do
notice this stro
being light effect in the clouds which
is pretty distracting
however testing for k60 stabilization
the Samsung actually does quite a bit
better than the iPhone in this situation
in this scenario we wanted to test out
the autofocus speed of 4k 24 on the
iPhone
compared to 8k 24 on the Samsung and so
far the iPhone is doing an excellent job
now on the s20 ultra and 8k you can tell
that it's having some major auto
focusing issues especially here towards
the end where it's not able to catch
focus at all now this shaw is meant to
compare detail between the iPhones 4k
and the Samsungs 8k now since we have
the extra crop on the s20 I cropped in a
little bit more on the iPhone which
actually makes the detail a little bit
worse but you guys let me know which one
looks better since the last shot was a
little bit shaky I set my camera rig
down on a table and once again we
cropped in a bit on the iPhone to match
the s20 and then we cropped in even more
so now you can definitely see that the a
K is much more detailed than on the
iPhone we decided to take this outside
and test the quality on this tree right
here we cropped in quite a bit on the
tree and although you do see quite a bit
more detail on the s20 you can
definitely see the extra noise and
cropping in also made the difference in
stabilization much more apparent now
switching the s20 ultra down to 4k we
can easily see that the iPhone has quite
a bit more detail and here's the s 20 s
4k compared to a K you can see that it
does have quite a bit more detail but it
also has more noise as well here's
another quality comparison between the
iPhones 4k in the s 20 s 8k if we take a
closer look it actually looks like the
iPhone has a little bit more detail than
the s 20 and if we really crop in we can
confirm that the iPhones 4k in medium to
low light is actually more detailed than
the s 20 s 8k now comparing detail
between the ultra wide cameras you can't
really tell unless you crop in and at
that point we can see that the Samsung
has a little bit more detail than the
iPhone this scenario is meant to test
dynamic range and from here you can't
really tell but if you crop into the
window you can tell that the shed on the
s 20 s image is more blown out than on
the iPhone and at the same time if we
crop into the darkest part of the image
we can see that the iPhone has better
dynamic range in the shadows as well but
the s20 has a little bit more detail in
this shot we compared the maximum zoom
of the iPhone which is six times
compared to the Samsung which we can
tell is definitely more detailed than
the iPhone another plus for the s20 is
that you can actually zoom up to 20
times in video mode and if we crop in on
the iPhones image to match the s20 we
can definitely see a ton of extra detail
on the Samsung now switching the Samsung
to 8k mode and zooming in six times we
actually see more detail on the iPhone
and that's because the s20 can only
shoot a k' using the main lens that
means it's cropping in six times on the
main lens which gives you less detail
than this hello photo lens on the iPhone
and here's the s 20s 4k with a telephoto
lens compared to a K on the main lens at
6 X zoom this shows us that you should
definitely not be using the a K mode if
you're planning on zooming in another
thing we discovered is that if you're
shooting 4k 60 on both the iPhone and
the Samsung the iPhone actually looks
better because 4k 60 is also limited to
the main lens on the s20 you can't shoot
4k 60 with the telephoto lens so if we
switch the s 20 down to 4k 30 we can
definitely see a lot more detail than on
the iPhone now going back to 4k 60 on
both phones but this time in low-light
the Samsung actually looks a little bit
better because the noise reduction is
doing a better job compared to the
iPhone now let's test a little bit more
low-light in this scene
comparing 4k 30 on both phones we can
see that the Samsung actually looks
better because is doing a better job at
noise reduction and compared to the
iPhone
however we do see some really weird
focus hunting on the s 20 that we don't
see on the iPhone
now switch into a K on the Samsung it
seems like the noise reduction has been
completely turned off because we're
seeing a lot of noise and we're also
seeing a ton of focus hunting now
comparing 4k on the ultra wide lenses
the iPhone is doing a ton of noise
reduction and it's honestly looking very
blurred out compared to the Samsung now
switching to the main lens the iPhone is
still overdoing it on the noise
reduction it doesn't look too bad but
you can't see the detail in the carpet
like you can on the s2
now for this shot we're comparing 2x
zoom quality and the Samsung is actually
using the main lens and cropping in two
times compared to the telephoto lens on
the iPhone so we are getting better
detail on the iPhone now if we go to 4x
the s20 is actually using its telephoto
4x lens so we're getting a lot more
detail and now comparing 4k selfie video
quality the s20 wins yet again in
low-light this shot is meant to test
dynamic range between 4k on the iPhone
and 8k on the s20 and if we crop into
the mountains we can see that the iPhone
has better dynamic range but the s20 has
quite a bit more detail in those trees
comparing detail in this scene you can't
really tell until you crop in and at
that point you can see a lot more detail
on the s 20s a K compared to 4k on the
iPhone and I do want to mention once
again that you can't shoot 4k 60 using
the ultra wide lens on the s 20 and this
tough dynamic range scene we can see
that the iPhone is choosing to keep the
foreground well expose to compare to the
s 20 which actually under exposes it so
there's a big difference between
exposure changes compared to a very nice
smooth change with the iPhone and
finally here's another shot testing
stabilization at 4k 60 on both the
iPhone and the s20 let us know which
phone you thought did a better job
overall in the comments section below
and make sure to click that circle above
to subscribe and check out one of those
two videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]